what do you guys uh do you love winning
or hate losing more
I definitely don't hate losing if it
pays the bills I don't mind oh really um
yeah but honestly if I win I feel more
relief than anything rather than like
excitement and stuff I'm like oh [__]
thank God that's over you know I hate
losing for sure
um but I understand that it's necessary
to get you know to get to where you want
to be
um and then winning is like I mean what
I think winning is probably the closest
you can think you can get to like heroin
or something because I mean we're on a
like if you do have extreme success in a
torment that you've been you know
adamant about training for and competing
in for a while and you end up winning it
I mean I feel like you're on that high
for days at a time afterwards heroin's
gonna be better you think so I'm I'm a
stick with no but I'm not gonna suck
dick to win
okay
I guess that's a good boy yeah
but you know like uh because you you
come from a little bit of a wrestling
culture one of the things I really love
is at the end of the match when they
lose they just there's no they just run
off
they're like almost pissed off it's like
some mixture of anger and frustration at
themselves I think I think sometimes
that people like freak out on the mat
and I think that's just a to show
everybody like they're acting like they
cared a lot and really maybe they didn't
work uh enough to to you know get to
where they want to where they expect it
to be and they lost and then they had
this big boost of emotion like after
their after their loss but uh yeah I
mean I shouldn't I think you just cry in
the mirror and not to everybody else you
know
um what have you ever cried watching a
movie I don't think I've ever cried
period okay have you cried and watched a
movie not yet not yet The Notebook I try
to avoid those but it's actually I lie
actually Titanic the last part of a
difficult wake up for me is I try to
find a sad movie and at least cry about
a pound out that really gets me over the
line low energy cutting the tears
[Laughter]
um there's other following uh liquids I
could talk to you about but let's just
let's just let's just continue on low
energy what uh
um what about you Nikki uh love of
winning versus hate of losing I'm a very
competitive person so I for sure hate
losing more than I like winning uh I I
do think it's something that's kind of
held me back over the uh the past few
years because uh it makes it so that I'm
not as active as I should be because
it's like I really hate that feeling of
you know after a match that you just
lost uh so it kind of prevents me from
competing so it's definitely something I
need to work past so like when you think
about a competition the possibility of
losing which is always there in
competition is the thing that like
weighs heavy on you in in the months and
weeks leading up to yeah my whole life
you know my financial stability
everything depends on you know my
ability to go out there and compete and
my ability to teach uh so you know it's
it's a huge hit to the brand if you lose
so you know leading up to matches that's
that's definitely something that's in my
mind I know you so you guys are like
world-class athletes but for me more
like a hobbyist competitor I compete a
lot
the thing I was uh because I really
wanted to win the thing I was probably
most afraid of is not just losing but
like embarrassing myself yeah even even
actually winning by stalling that was
the thing I hated the most about myself
in terms of crying in the mirror is like
being too afraid
you take risks after I'm up on two
points or something I think you got a
competition sometimes it's good to take
the emotion out of it it's too easy
sometimes to like uh think about all my
girls and in the crowd my family's
watching like I want to win because
they're there but at the highest level
of your emotional at all no that's
affecting you
yeah that's tough though
that's tough especially like leading up
to when you're on the map maybe but
leading up to it I think it's okay to be
emotional prior like you know if we know
80cc or is coming up and we have a big
match like definitely I'll go out in
practice and I'll I'll visualize I'll
put myself in that competition that way
when it's game time it's like I've been
there a thousand times already so not
the actual competition but even leading
up to it like stepping on the mat like
all the walk the walk towards it all
that all that stuff like I'll do the
same exact warm-up for weeks on end and
until my competition day comes that way
that way you know when I compete I'm
just like oh it's another Tuesday at
practice
uh what about you Craig how do you
prepare mentally for terminal like ADCC
I pushed you completely out of my mind
don't even think about it try to avoid
any visualization any rituals warm-ups
anything like that block it out until
the last second yeah try not to think
about it I just got to training to have
fun learn a bit so I try to approach
competition the exact same way I don't
warm up uh training do very little
warm-up for competition
and you just step on the mat step on the
mats My Philosophy is there's no
warm-ups on the street
we're so vastly different
all right uh so you look legit don't
warm up no I probably should now I'm 31
but I was just like in the gym take it
easy the first round you know like if I
look around the room and Nikki Ryan said
I might go all right we'll have an
easier first round today
so even for like the most high stakes
matches
you try to push it out you don't even
think about it
what about like all the social like
Instagram posts you have to do about
that match you just make a joke out of
it and kind of yeah I mean that actually
kind of pretty silly you know which is
wrestling each other you know yeah we
put the meaning into it but to someone
that doesn't follow the sport it looks
stupid well all of human existence is
pretty silly like what are we doing none
of us really know what's going on we'll
kind of have sex to reproduce we get
hungry we eat and then we're all chasing
money in cars and whatever the Hell in a
capital Society or we worship a dictator
in a authoritarian regime yeah and then
we get off on we'll let power abuse us
and then we just murder others because
we get off on it yeah
and then eventually all of us will die
because the sun will run out of energy
because colonizing other planets is very
difficult it's another what matters it's
a good uh good philosophy it's pretty
pretty good that's exactly how does the
sun run out of energy
well you caught me there
uh burn out it's like a it's a nuclear
fusion engine that eventually burns out
like when you get tired of training yeah
it's never happened I try to get tired I
was like dude it's not working
all right cool cool so you legit don't
care about losing it doesn't weigh heavy
on you I try not to listen like if I win
I try to block out all the compliments
all the niceties and stuff so I try to
do the same with losing it's happened
move on to the next one you know don't
dwell on it too much and sometimes make
a joke out of it yeah exactly winning or
losing
with the right joke we can make money
off of the events just transpired that's
what's most important excellent thank
you I have a bunch of your merch oh nice
this one's the Jordan borrowers ripoff
uh all I see is silver
the way pronounce Burrows is is very is
very very sexy okay
um I throw lions at people and I try to
guess your reaction like sometimes I'll
say Santa Nikki and I'll be like all
right that's probably crossing the line
you know I mean we'll tone it down to
the public so yeah yeah so it's not just
right you have to think because it's
crossing the line yeah yeah I get as
close to it as possible yeah I feel like
you can't really cross it
just just a little bit just a little bit
yeah okay